hey youtubers it's Charlie thank you
everybody that submitted questions on my
Game of Thrones video a lot of people
wondering about your on Greyjoy Horn of
winter is real is it not real is it the
thing that's going to help bring the
wall crashing down so for the most part
we just we have to wait for news from
the set let's get going though so
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
season five or you're not caught up on
the show yet here we go first question
victor asks do you think that Targaryen
have a warg sort of power to connect
with their dragons I definitely think
it's hereditary
but dragon bonding I think has some
components that get into like blood
magic things that the show and George or
Martin haven't explained yet if you
haven't read the short story the
princess and the Queen it deals with the
dance of the Dragons the Targaryen Civil
War it kind of gets into dragon bonding
a little bit more there's just there's a
lot more people riding dragons fighting
each other on the show we just saw
Daenerys ride rogue on so we're just now
seeing more visual examples of how
Daenerys is connected to her dragons I
don't want to say working is a deeper
ability but it's like you're literally
transporting your consciousness to
another body so it seems even more
powerful Daenerys his ability still
seems kind of like a passive ability
like she isn't calling dro pond rogue on
just kind of senses that she's in danger
and comes to help her at least that's
the way that Dan and Dave explained it
the way they try to do it on the show
like there have been cases where dogs
will try to help their owners when they
sense that they're in grave danger
working would be like you get in danger
and then you transplant your
consciousness into your dog's body and
then use them to run and get help so I
think Daenerys his ability to control
her dragons is more of like a
relationship like you would have with
your pet you can train them to a certain
degree but they still have free will
next question Frederico asks I didn't
read the books but it looks to me like
the Horn of winter is more of a legend
than a real thing
could it be manses way to keep all the
free people on his side
I definitely think he talks a big talk
but he wouldn't have been able to stay
king of the free folk if he hadn't been
able to back it up usually the way to do
that is just to be a great mediator and
give people what they think that they
want or at least let them think that
you're going to give them what they
think they want it probably would have
been to his benefit to downplay mystical
artifacts though because the more you
hype stuff up like that the more
dangerous it gets
if you don't deliver outside of his
inner circle I am kind of curious like
outside of tormund Giantsbane Lord of
bones like all the people in and around
manse like in his close inner circle I'm
wondering how much the free folk knew
about the Horn of winter next question
Lulu seed asks why is it that everyone
talks about different religions and
different gods and no one mentions the
drowned God I want a video on Ironborn
culture a bunch of unpronounceable
things I'm not even gonna try to
pronounce those so yeah okay Ironborn
the problem with the Ironborn is is that
the show is kind of like push them off
to the side it sounds like we're gonna
be getting more Ironborn stuff in season
6 so really you're not gonna start
seeing a lot of Ironborn talk happening
until we get episodes I was never a
giant fan of the Ironborn they're
certainly interesting but there are a
terrible bunch of people like I mean if
you really like characters that are bad
like if you like Ramsay type characters
then you probably also like the Ironborn
just like we don't give enough about
anything we're gonna do whatever we want
screw the king so most the times when
I'm doing videos I try to focus on stuff
that the show is doing just because
that's like that common point of
reference for most people but if we do
get a lot of Ironborn stuff in season
six then I will totally do a lot more
Ironborn videos next question huh Tariq
asks do you think that the phrase could
be touched upon in the upcoming season
or even in winds of winter especially
since they're powerful player elevated
by the Lannisters well I mean the phrase
are always going to be important because
they control the twins and if you want
to get an army into the north that's the
only way to do it unless you sail them
all the way around there were some
rumors about Walder Frey going to
Belfast so we might get some free stuff
I actually kind of thought that they
were gonna drop it until the actor that
plays Walder Frey was like I think I'm
coming back I'm not sure it's always
kind of vague when actors say that and
the actors that we know are coming back
aren't saying anything like if he were
actually coming back he would be under a
nondisclosure agreement so he wouldn't
be able to say that he's coming back but
just talking about the show there's a
couple different places they could show
up they they'd be of use so there's the
North remembers storyline that's gonna
be happening Sansa's on the run right
now they're casting some northern Lords
so they could get caught up in a
northern revenge storyline like revenge
for the red wedding and I don't think
there's any way that they're going to be
left out of the books completely next
question James asks do you think that
they'll still do the Horn of winter and
other bits and later season
just with different characters attached
to link it in so you mean just like
skipping over it now and then bringing
it back later they are doing some things
like that in season six like they passed
the books but they're grabbing little
bits that they skipped from previous
books and doing them in season six like
The Citadel I think it's totally
possible but I'm not expecting any Deo
sex machina situations whereby like a
powerful artifact turns the tide of a
battle dan and Dave have talked about
the way that they feed viewers
information they usually they assume
that you don't know anything about the
books so if they want to do a storyline
it has to flow logically from things
that have already happened on the show
like they've been teasing lyanna stark's
so they're probably gonna be doing some
more lyanna stark's stuff otherwise
there would have been no reason for
Sansa to have that conversation with
Littlefinger in the tombs at Winterfell
so if the Horn of winter is gonna be a
big thing on the show just expect people
to start talking about it in the early
episodes before something actually
happens with it like someone isn't just
gonna grab it in episode 9 and blow it
without them teasing it before that it
would be really crazy if benjin came
back with the Horn of winter but I'm
hoping that we see benjin again through
brans storyline still alive until
confirmed dead I know a lot of people
think that he's the night's king but the
night's Kings facial structure just
looks way too different for him to be
Benjen stark they'd have to recast the
actor and it'd feel like a big middle
finger without them setting that up next
question Andrew asks after a lengthy
discussion and my sister I came to a few
possible conclusions when the war for
the throne will end at season seven and
whoever's left standing will battle
White Walkers in season 8 or number two
the war for the throne doesn't ever
really end there just aren't that many
people left over after the war with the
White Walkers so just the answer I think
logically what's gonna happen is is
people will realize that there is a
bigger threat than just fighting each
other for the Iron Throne
so by season 8 by like the final big
battle war for the dawn however it goes
down there won't be a lot of infighting
amongst the Great Houses a bunch of
high-profile people will end up dying
then they'll come to an arrangement and
pick the strongest candidate to become
the next king of the Seven Kingdoms
somebody to uphold a truce maybe
somebody to keep the peace that's why a
lot of people are writing fan fiction
about Daenerys getting married to Jon
Snow and then being king
Queen of the Seven Kingdoms but if
there's a truce to be made to win any
final battle you guys can write your own
fanfiction about who you think should be
put in that arranged marriage someone
has to take the throne and they have to
get married and have successors so say
what you will about the nurse being
barren there been some clues in the
books that that might not be the case
but we'll see next question josè asks
the producers have addressed a specific
scene that they had no idea how to do in
season 5 due to its size in amounts of
CG they moved it to season 6 and I'm
thinking it's the wall coming down well
that would be like a huge thing I'm not
really sure what comment you're
referring to I don't remember the the
producer saying that but if they did
they could be talking about a couple
things they could be talking like about
a really big flashback scene the doom of
Valyria would be a good option I think
it's a little bit early for the wall to
be coming down I think that that
wouldn't happen until we start seeing
White Walkers much much closer to it and
if they're going to be explaining a lot
of the magic on the show then doing
flashbacks can help add a lot of context
especially through Valyrian flashbacks
which even George R Martin hasn't done
yet he did say there would be some
Valyrian flashbacks in the books but he
hasn't done them yet he didn't say winds
of winter or dream of spring but I'm
guessing probably both books so the
takeaway is just that the wall coming
down isn't the only big CG thing that
they could do but it definitely would be
one of the most badass that'd be the
perfect IMAX episode next question
Freddy yes do you think that Dany and
John would meet at all if so would it be
as enemies or as allies well I think you
know assuming that Jon Snow comes back
in some form earth shape I think he
would be mistrustful of her at first
especially because she would be arriving
with a major force especially with the
dragons if there's anybody that has any
common sense in them though it is John
so he would probably be the first to see
okay they're probably not trying to kill
us they probably would have done that
already if that was their plan so we
need to find a way to work together if
he was able to jump through the mental
hoops that it took to go help the
wildlings in Episode eight then he can
totally jump through those hoops again
to work with Daenerys in her army but
that is all based on the assumption that
he is coming back next question FES
since they seem to be merging parts of
Aegon young Griff storyline with
Daenerys is do you think that she'll
head to Dorne in season six well
actually I kind of think that you
probably gonna rescue herself I think
that'd be more interesting but as for
heading to Dorne a lot of that depends
on what they cut out what they do with
the door and characters because it seems
to be like a dramatic departure for the
books for that storyline I really want
to think that Prince Doran has like some
grand master plan like I want to believe
in the Dornish master plan like he's
secretly been working with Varys in the
Targaryen restoration but that remains
to be seen they could completely cut
that storyline out they have been
filming a whole lot in Spain so it
sounds like there's gonna be a lot of
interesting things happening in Dorne we
just don't know what yet my guess is
though that someone from Dorne would try
to treat with Daenerys before she would
try to treat with Dorne next question
Alyssa asks curious on your predictions
for things that could take place at the
wall if Jon comes back will he be going
for revenge
what about torment in the wildlings what
will they do if Jon doesn't come back
well the wildling like if Jon doesn't
come back I'll start with that they
would have to just find a way to survive
on the gift in the remaining nights
watch people that the dirtbags would
probably just cut them off like they
just they wouldn't help him anymore I
think I've talked about it before but if
Jon does come back I don't think he
turned around and just started stabbing
all the Nights Watch people that
betrayed him but he probably would chop
at least one person set off the rest of
them would probably soak out with fear
at the idea that he has a certain level
of immortality like he can come back
from the dead that they would just crap
their pants surprise surprise there's
nothing you can do to get rid of me so
you better bow down as for other stuff I
really do think that we're gonna see the
White Walkers move on the wall by the
end of the season we saw that episode
eight battle so the White Walkers are
gonna be back they're not they're not
that far like hardhome isn't that far
from the wall the White Walkers can move
their army pretty quickly but thank you
so much everyone for so many questions
these are always a ton of fun to do I'm
really interested to see what kind of
stuff comes from the set in the next
couple months we started to see some
pictures and there's always rumors about
actors going but really you start to go
crazy what you see actors in costume on
set congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Mike fu and a $20 Amazon
gift card just be sure to message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact info and shout out to James
and Sophie happy anniversary I'm always
happy to give people shout outs on like
anniversaries and birthdays and stuff I
always like hearing about families that
watch my videos together
which is why I try try not to curse too
much because some people watch the
videos with their children even if their
children aren't allowed to watch Game of
Thrones on television Ben Affleck has
even told funny stories about searching
YouTube with his kid looking for frozen
videos for him to watch just picture him
singing let it go with his little kid in
his Batman costume sad Batman sings the
Disney hits that is why YouTube will
always be so much more fun than actual
TV so right now I'm taking suggestions
for next week's bonus video be sure to
subscribe to get that it does it didn't
think specifically you guys want just
let me know there's still all kinds of
stuff we can talk about I'll think about
doing some Ironborn stuff to Italy at
least as non-spoilery as possible but
well you guys wait for that you can
click here to learn all about Arthur
Dayne and the Tower of joy and you can
click here to learn all about Jaime
Lannister's history also kind of kind of
crosses over with Arthur Dayne a little
bit thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you